be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so I still have a head cold right
mind my throat is sore and I've got got
a whole roll of toilet paper right
basically my tissue paper to blow my
nose I've got my Vaseline to keep my
nose from drying out you can't stop
greatness son we are picking back up
again with absolute carnage now here's
the thing right the last thing we picked
up with this like The Incredible Hulk
became the new host for venom which was
cool
it's really really awesome to see like I
definitely Doug Doug SIA that the issue
is that it just ended with the
Incredible Hulk becoming venom so we had
no idea what he was capable of we had no
idea what it was that he could do and
the reality of this is we get to see
this play out in the next issue like in
this this particular issue of absolute
carnage but here's the thing about
absolute carnage as much as the story is
titled absolute carnage
it's about absolute carnage in so much
as he's just the villain who's there the
story's about Eddie Brock and that's
what I really dig about this right I
mean of course it has carnage and of
course he's the main villain and you get
to see like a really good display of his
character in terms of how he's handled
by Donnie Cates but in reality I'm not
really seeing anything here from from
carnage that I haven't seen before what
I like is the evolution of Eddie Brock
and nothing really shows it better than
this moment that he has a Peter Parker
as soon as it all goes down right
because with any losing the Venom
symbiote he's just a guy now and there's
nothing he could do to stop carnage he's
hopelessly outmatched against carnage
and even with venom he was still
struggling right so what little hope he
had was basically gone here Peter Parker
himself the best he can do is bob and
weave and dodge carnage right like using
his spider sense to try to get the upper
hand but he can't outright defeat
carnage because of how powerful he is
now right so but the cool thing about
this is is that what you end up having
is is a really cool it's actually a
really really great reference here
what is up happening is Donnie Cates
references the jury that's a jury this
is an organization I haven't heard of in
decades right in a long long time the
jury was an organization created by
David michaleen II and Mark Bagley back
in a venom lethal protector number two
and 93 or whatever it was that story
came out and the jury was actually kind
of like this anti-venom task force is
really what it was right so the idea
behind this was that you had a guy named
oral Taylor I think was oral oral Taylor
anyway he was a general the military his
son was a prison guard and he was
actually a prison guard at an
institution that was essentially the
wrath before the raft it was for
supervillains essentially envenomate his
escape and in Hue died in the
and as a result of that Orwell ended up
gathering together all of Hugh's friends
in creating a task force to track down
and try to destroy venom it didn't
succeed but it was a really cool concept
and the fact that like Donny Cades is
gonna reach back to like 1993 and say
remnants of this group are still around
it's cool
and the reason here's a reason why it's
so cool here's the reason why this
matters is because what it does is it
creates cohesiveness and cohesiveness is
something that oftentimes is lost when
it comes to writers crafting stories
especially events that focus on a
character that they're taking over
because so much emphasis is put on how
they perceive the character but
oftentimes like old school stuff is lost
and so is it's really cool to see a
writer kind of say hey look like
remnants of this old school stuff is is
important here and I guess it's a
significant thing it matters it's
awesome to see these throw backs it's
awesome to see these really really cool
moments where it kind of hits back and
harkens back to their really the old
school stories now the other cool thing
here and this is why I say like Donnie
Cates handling of Eddie Brock I think is
second to none this is the single best
handling of Eddie Brock that we've ever
seen in Marvel Comics and the reason why
is because he sits down and talks with
Peter and he says I can't protect these
guys you know I can't do it on my own
like as a singular guy I can't do it on
my own
and right now it's just you and me and
somebody's got to protect the boys
somebody's got to keep them safe that's
your job
you stay here you keep them safe I'm
gonna grab some of this jury tech I'm
gonna go out there and I'm gonna fight
off carnage carnage is doppelganger
forces as best I can
this is awesome because one of the cool
things that comes out of this is is
literally like any broad gets out there
and he's just like all I hear is the
screaming of these carnage things but
it's almost a little bit of like a
reprieve right it's almost kind of like
Zim like in peaceful because he's like
the one thing I don't hear is a voice in
my head I don't hear venom telling me
what to do I don't hear a venom giving
me orders telling me Eddie don't do that
Eddie you have to run like I don't hear
that it's just me and he's like I'm
Eddie Brock like I can be a hero I'm a
good guy and by god if I'm gonna go down
today I'm gonna go down swinging there's
one of the coolest moments of his
character like ever in the history of
like Eddie Brock do it's so beast
because what you're talking about here
is you're talking about a guy who's
basically gone from like an arch an arch
enemy of Peter Parker who wanted to kill
him to a guy who's now putting the life
of his son in the hands of Peter to keep
it safe and is gonna put his life on the
line and knowing full well he might die
get out there and take as many of these
carnage guys down with him as he
possibly can it's a whole sale
revamp of Eddie Brock and that's why I
love it so much that's why it's so
awesome because it's a total reformation
of a character who in reality had this
coming a long time ago I guess this
really should have happened a long time
ago but it's cool to see it happen now
now the big question a lot of people had
is how with the Incredible Hulk with the
Venom symbiote fare against carnage
first things first
they credible Hulk look so amazing is as
venom right like he looks so beast and I
definitely want to see it make its
return but here's the thing about the
Incredible Hulk
alright we're not talking about like Doc
green Hulk right like the super genius
version of The Incredible Hulk we're
talking about what's essentially the
immortal Hulk assuming that this falls
in line with what's going on with with
Al Ewing's immortal hope run this is not
the sharpest tool in the shed immortal
Hulk and end savage Hulk they're like
forces of nature just like punching and
pummeling things but they're by no means
the sharpest tool in the shed
battle tactics strategies these things
are lost on the Incredible Hulk in his
most pure savage and current immortal
form and it's kind of a cool thing to
see because when you end up having
cletus kasady
who's been around the block more than a
few times and is by no means Captain
America but is by every means more
capable than your average superhero he
gets the one up on him like that in the
blink of an eye and it would be really
easy to look at that and say what a
waste like what a huge colossal waste
but I would say this is really designed
to highlight just how capable carnage is
that even when you have one of the most
powerful beings in the Marvel Universe
and just sheer physical strength who
puts on a symbiote which amplifies his
power even further and still gets taken
over by carnage it's a sight to behold
it's just like wow because what it does
is it illustrates the gravity of the
situation and it says what hope do they
have and all this really begins to come
by way of Eddie Brock himself and the
reason why is because using one of the
devices that belong to the jury which I
believe it wasn't the chakra everyone it
belonged to but it's one that emits an
electric pulse what he does is each
handle two channels it through Captain
America shield now people who are
knowledgeable about Captain America
shield will say okay so Captain America
shield is a proto adamantium slash
vibranium iron alloy that was created by
Myron MacLean accidental
right attempts to duplicate Captain
America shield is what led to the
creation of pure adamantium the
adamantium is founded Wolverine's
skeleton and so because it's a vibranium
alloy technically speaking it should
basically absorb the electric shock
right I mean activate or it could absorb
kinetic energy almost all different
forms of energy it should basically
absorb that but you would look at that
and you would say either the shield
would absorb it but it wouldn't like
electrocute Miles Morales leaves it's
thought not something that we're
familiar with the answer to that
question is actually yes it can now the
reason why is if you go back and you
look at Captain America comics number 78
1954 I love being able to pull out
little nuggets like this because I feel
like people are just like what holy cow
how did this guy know about this then
Captain America comics number 78 1954
there was a character who was created
called the like the electro monster
something like that model would reuse
the concept later on when they
introduced electro in the spider-man
comics but this was a character who's
created by the Russians for the purpose
of like defeating Captain America now
EDD Brubaker's run all that kind of
stuff not really Steve Rogers doesn't
really matter the fact remains when they
go and they fire this electric shock at
Captain America shield what half the
American is up doing is absorbing it and
amplifying it back now we get how to go
with that or we can ignore and the
reason why is because if you read ed
Brubaker's run on Captain America
basically every version of the character
that we saw after the end of World War 2
was not really Steve Rogers and it was
not really Captain America shield they
were frozen and ice basically we found
that out in Avengers number 4 so you can
ignore or you can go with it you can say
well at the time the story was written
it was Captain America it was Captain
America shield it wasn't until we got
into the mid-2000s whatever Baker
changed all that so you can do whatever
you want with it you can you can ignore
it you could choose to go with it I like
the idea of going with it because I
think it kind of makes a scene makes
sense a little bit more or you can just
say the electricity passed through the
shield in shock Miles Morales doesn't
really matter regardless of the scenario
because electricity fire things like
that are weaknesses to symbiotes and
because of the fact that Miles Morales
had previously used his venom blast to
kind of jog Eddie Brock out of being
controlled by carnage this is basically
Eddie Brock recalling that and then
using it on miles and then bringing
models back but this is a huge moment
because we would look at this and we
would say okay cool
one more Ally to Assad now they have a
chance miles is just like dude we're so
screwed and when the questions like why
is like because literally like being
credible Holt taking the Venom symbiote
or at least the venison Viet bonding
it's stuffed in a Incredible Hulk and
then it fighting against carnage The
Incredible Hulk doesn't have the
wherewithal to intellectually overcome
Cletus Kasady physically yes but all
Cletus has to do is out-think him that's
exactly what happens when that time
comes Cletus Kasady is gonna seize
control of the Venom symbiote and when
he does the Venom symbiote is get a
rebound itself - Cletus and it's gonna
amplify his power even more because each
time he takes a codex he becomes more
powerful and so it's just kind of like
okay so like literally at that moment
cassadee strips the Venom symbiote off
of Roose Manor when he like forces the
Incredible Hulk to revert back to Bruce
strips of venom simian off of him
amplifies his power even more and then
essentially just kind of like no one can
stop me now and for the most part they
can't write like by that point with the
10-minute window that was bought by
Eddie Brock in order to basically allow
the superheroes to wake up from their
code X's being removed they jump in as
best they can but they're no match for
Cletus Kasady and he takes them out with
a quickness not only that will we end up
learning from Miles is that where the
maker the ultimate universe version of
Reed Richards at the beginning of the
story who is basically you know who
claimed that he was extracting these
codices and then destroying them wasn't
doing that he was actually saving them
he was basically putting them in this
great big huge storage device more or
less and so the result is that like all
these codices are they're all cars would
have to do is break into it and so the
result is that like by all standards of
measurement Cletus Kasady has more or
less one but what is up happening here
is Eddie Brock seems to make the
sacrifice to say okay fine if that's the
case if that's where all the codices are
then let's go get them and so Eddie
Brock in like this amazing heroic moment
but he's literally going through and
saying all this he's like he's like
under all the noise and under all the
chaos of it all the panic and it all
like the fear and all this rage and
everything that's going on like under
all of that I can feel somebody that I
haven't felt in a long long time
I can feel hope and so what he does is
he literally breaks into this entire
storage facility and basically absorbs
all these codices into himself and when
he does it amplifies his power up higher
than it was when he was originally venom
and then from that point he basically
goes forward and ends up chasing after
Cletus Kasady at which point the story
ends well that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
guys are new here to come as explained
make sure you guys have a sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like cliffhangers and I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]